[Music]
Charlie Sheen making his comeback he
excited about that that's four of you I
think 20 I believe what you call a
wait-and-see attitude yeah now it's true
on the Today show this morning Charlie
Sheen gave an interview he said he
cringes when he watches footage of his
crazy rants from last year
yes Sheen said he's moved on he's now
focusing on his new career as a JetBlue
pilot
[Music]
that's my Charlie Sheen right there in
the jaw and sighs speaking of JetBlue
that's a crazy story yeah I let that
kind of lost it
the copilot on the JetBlue flight is now
saying the pilot was making crazy
remarks even while they were still on
the ground yeah they knew he had really
lost his mind when he announced ladies
and gentlemen we are scheduled for an
on-time departure yeah I'd have gotten
right off that yeah right
no way fascinating rumor on the campaign
trail it's been reported that Mitt
Romney and Newt Gingrich had a secret
meeting apparently Romney asked Gingrich
if he'd considered being his running
mate and Gingrich asked Romney are you
gonna finish those fries
put some in for later these are for
later
yesterday Mitt Romney this guy has
trouble connecting with a common man
yesterday MIT Romney told what he
thought was a humorous story about how
his father closed down a Michigan
factory yeah
then Romney went on to quote some of his
favorite jokes from the movie
Schindler's List so he guys on a roll
[Applause]
lines you like a lot of touch
speaking of political foe pause
yesterday Joe Biden flubbed a speech
when he accidentally thanked dr. pepper
instead of a woman named dr. paper then
Biden apologized and said that he meant
no disrespect so
[Music]
Smike data like that yeah drink because
of Biden soda addiction yeah have you
heard this story Google has apparently
invented a self-driving car have you
heard about this okay one guy I could I
can work with that this is for you pal
no in California this is I guess they
did an experiment an experimental
self-driving car invented by Google took
a blind man to Taco Bell yeah when the
man realized where he was he told the
car hey I'm blind not high
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know how you feel about this
Olympics story it's been talked about a
lot but the Olympics has ruled this is a
new rule that female beach volleyball
players may now wear something that
covers them up more than a bikini no no
the the ruling was made after the debut
of women's volleyball champion bushy
Betty
[Applause]
[Music]
you look lotted that
that was a test and then people failed
oh yeah
[Laughter]
just be happy I don't have a picture to
go along with that joke Wow